I'm so tired I'm so tired I had enough
stop calling me
kazoo kid or else it's not funny anymore
it's not a meme this shitty meme has to
stop just cuz I got one bad haircut
Justin meet everyone added that haircut
in the 90s by the way so just because I
had it as a kid as well
doesn't mean I'm Kazuki just cuz this is
me just not mean I'm Kazuki [ __ ] piss
me off so much this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
not funny
stop no no this is not funny either
alright so for those of you don't know
casue kid we're gonna go through it now
in case for some reason you haven't
[ __ ] seen this [ __ ] kid wow you
know a lot of times when I do my intro
actually it's like haha [ __ ] who does
that oh hey wait a minute
sorry sorry I just remember the lines
are you how can you talk like that like
you hear his [ __ ] boy just go like
wait a minute I'll tell you a secret
why sometimes I get a little quiet when
I meet lots of new kids you know what I
think we're gonna be friends please no
please no I don't want to be what is why
is his face too [ __ ] creepy
my hair is not scary like that we will
never be friends
mr. kid because we have absolutely
nothing in common what I like to do is
sing I like to dance dance pretend
pretend
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] were the same and when I'm
with friends I like to have fun she
seems [ __ ] awesome Jonathan you need
to [ __ ] in shell okay Karl well no one
gives a [ __ ] Jesus Christ [ __ ] I like to
kazoo me hold on I'm pretty pretty
pretty sure you can't do anything but I
guess let's pretend more I love that
line because it's so incredibly dubbed
let's pretend more it's so incredibly
dubbed by like a like an adult woman I
am an adult woman yoohoo kids oh the
pretended Jonathan is just destroying
this shot by getting in the middle of
the camera why the [ __ ] are you walking
right through I thought I thought I like
this in the background what the [ __ ] is
it with you what don't you [ __ ]
understand
[Music]
why am I the only one getting likes I
tannic undertones from there's some kind
of cult weird cult [ __ ] from this kazoo
thing partner I want to sing just for
you you here my friends
[Music]
special friends
[Applause]
let's say I remember now it's all coming
back to me I used to love playing makisu
it was like a friend of man it was my
best friend why are we still here just
suffer
every night I can feel my leg
and my heart
even my fingers
the body has lost the comrades have lost
stop hurting
[Music]
[Applause]
let me tell you a secret it's pretty
realistic sometimes I get it up quiet
meaning you're gonna be friends special
friends and when are with my friends I
like to have fun I like to sing dance
pretend and and ping-pong well is it
[Music]
the pretend spirit let's pretend more
you gotta use your hips
so a little better Ras let's pretend
more the secret summoning ritual
[Music]
he will rise again his mortal flesh will
once again walk upon this earth with his
master culinary skills the moon is in
the power the stars are aligned the time
has the spirit of Ainsley's we summon
upon me
[Music]
[Applause]
Master you have written ah
you had returned
I did this at you told
that please grant me immortality
fool do you not see you cannot be
forgiven
you killed me sent me to the fires of
hell for all eternity your soul is mine
but hey why don't we just put put that
aside for a minute and play the kazoo
what do you say old pal old partner for
good old times like we used to you
played so beautifully I wish one day I
can be at your level Master fool I have
been trained by the devil himself
you will never attain my power never you
Swedish what what's that another video
that they can think up they were now
under my control
they are my minions of death they are my
bros now my god execute order 66 order